uh steven of course you and ian go way
back oh oh well
ian was very kindly and very graciously
was in our show extras playing a twisted
version of himself and it's still one of
my proudest moments and one of my
funniest
i just i don't know if people saw it but
it was where
ian is supposedly giving sort of acting
lessons to ricky's character and just
saying how do i act so well
how do i know where to stand it's
written someone shows me
how do i know what to say it's written
in this
it was just an absolute joy and it was
the first time i'd ever worked with an
actor of sort of ian's calibre and just
seeing
just being behind the monitor and just
seeing him kind of be moving outside
just watching him in the room
just bringing it to life it was i can't
wait to see you on stage because it must
be electrifying it's the one the best
scripts i've i've ever had to learn and
perform the laughs just fall
out of you because of the the the way
the things written and up tonight i
thought it was ricky gervais who takes
all the credit for everything
but now i realize that stephen had more
than a hand in i thank you very very
much and if you want to see it it's on
youtube sometimes late at night if i'm
feeling really unhappy and alone and
want cheering up i i look it up and and
my head off
[Applause]
[Music]
you